are you worried you're addicted to your
smartphone if so here's a little
historical quiz can you guess what this
quotation is referring to parents have
become aware of a puzzling change in the
behavior patterns of their children they
cannot lock out this intruder because it
has gained an invincible hold of their
children
this quote isn't too remote smartphones
or even TV or computer games answer it's
actually from 1936 and still keep up the
radio and how about this one of the most
serious unreported disabling antisocial
diseases in America today okay so this
quote is talking about phone addiction
for the phones in question are landlines
remember them well there was a time when
people worried about how addictive they
were we see today concern over social
media before it was the Internet then we
had video nasties television radios in
the mall
meet Kirsten drop now professor of Media
Studies at the University of Southern
Denmark how many did I get too he's been
writing about this topic for over twenty
years the name I coined for it is is a
media panic but whenever a new medium
arrives on the social scene is taken up
in a big way then we see these very very
stark emotional reactions according to
custom when you look through history one
can see the same pattern of concern
repeating itself often even using the
same language and metaphors so today
there's lots of talk of social media
addiction comparing it to drugs but it's
easy to forget that pac-man pinball and
television were described in the same
way or reports talk of the addictive
dark side of social media occurring the
way that computer games were described
or another example social media is
compared to opiates the same language
that was used to describe television and
Nintendo and the drugs metaphor goes
further back what you think was
described as the marijuana of the
nursery because they were so addictive
the answer
comic books which by the middle of the
20th century had caught people so
worried about their addictiveness that
there were bestsellers about harm they
were doing young people official
inquiries even public burnings okay
lasts quite nothing but narcotics as
disruptive a real life and real living
as cocaine as destructive as cocaine
that would be the novel novels are silly
novels were innovating novels were the
worst form of mental food novels were
narcotic novels were addictive this is
Anki mukherjee from the University of
Oxford and she's talking about the time
when lots of people were genuinely
worried about people reading but you had
reviewers of children's literature
writing in journals saying this is
terrible for children it's terrible for
children to be given books it was feared
they would become addicted and this is
Frank Freddie who's written extensively
about this phenomenon and pretty much in
the same way that we see the social
media today being responsible for
uncivil behavior and for a variety of
sins so tuna in the 18th century the
novel was the target of of that kind of
criticism you can find novels described
as evil as a vice and blamed for
violence and yet today if anything
people are worried that young people are
not reading enough novels
[Music]
whether it's radio telephones comic
books or novels we see a similar party
there's a kind of historical amnesia
that media for example that 20 years ago
we're really really you know the object
of concern then all of a sudden we don't
hear very much about it I think
something that's helpful for thinking
about media panics is the Gartner hype
cycle developed by a US company and used
to describe the way technologies are
adopted by society according to this
theory new technology often has a moment
of enthusiasm and high expectations when
it seems like it might be the solution
to everything it's being called
revolution this is then followed by a
crash a period of disillusionment and
skepticism before both - fear level off
and everyone basically can't doubt but
with media panics while the
concerns about each particular media
might fade the overall state of anxiety
continues but something new who fills
the gap so why do you media panics keep
recurring one straightforward
explanation for media panics is that
adults have a natural parental concern
of the young not remembering because
they were children at the time that the
generation before had similar worries
about them another possible explanation
something called the third personal
effect which describes a tendency to
believe that other people would be more
affected by a media message than you are
this is how we can have no problem
reconciling our own pretty benign
experiences between media technology
with the belief that it will cause much
greater harm to others there's a very
negative impoverish here what human
beings are in a lot of the discussion on
the media they are really really too
stupid they're uneducated they cannot
deal with the complexities of everyday
life and therefore they become pretty
much the prisoners of the media a final
theory is to do with something social
scientists call cultural capital the
idea is that along with economic capital
and social capital one thing that
establishes your position in society is
your knowledge about culture and this is
especially true for those most of you
concerned about a medium to middle class
people who can't fall back on landed
property they invest a lot in themselves
in order to get on in society they
invest a lot in education in operating
according to the right cultural norms
but when you types of media come along
it threatens their investment in these
old forms of cultural capital so no
wonder they react nervously it's also
precarious investment because they live
in a do not dynamic society and modern
society through the 18th century and on
it's based on change considers an
addiction currently there's a debate
going on about smartphones and social
media with some scientists arguing
there's evidence for harm while many
others are unconvinced
but while it makes sense to be cautious
knowing the history of media panics
should help give us some perspective I'm
also a parent and I'm also a grandparent
and I'm also concerned and I think it's
fine to be concerned because it's and
the it's a kind of indication that you
take responsibility but I think there's
a difference between being concerned and
panicking because if you panic you can't
think we don't know what effect social
media and smartphones will have
long-term on our society but what we do
know is that as long as we keep
inventing new forms of media the cycle
of panic is likely to continue
[Music]